peu
m
je
bonjour vous le savez tous les mois
toutes les quatre semaines exactement lé
christian morin nous vous présentons une
nouvelle émission qui destiné aux jeunes
carrasso rennes on se rend compte que
nous avons aussi un public de jeunes et
nous voulons commencer à leur expliquer
la cuisine la cuisine en fête est ce que
c'est vraiment le but aujourd'hui mon
corps non c'est une forme c'est un
dérivé
on ne peut pas nier le progrès et il se
trouve qu'à l'heure actuelle en france
nous sommes un tout petit peu
envahissante par une sorte de
restauration qui s'appelle le fast food
et qui vous font des hamburgers alors
mon ami christian et moi même avons
décidé de vous faire des hamburgers
telle erreur par les choses des
hamburgers le pain alors je pars n'a été
en amérique tous les deux pour voir tout
ça est quant à lui rentré dans les
supermarchés on a vu des pins mission
mots qui ont l'air très beau et con qui
les touchent ces pins rien dedans c'est
du coton les enfants il se passe rien
peugeot alors nous on voulait tous vers
la paix un petit peu rebondi partout tu
accroches un fil au bout ça avant le
tout seul chez du match nul au sérieux
alors nous avons décidé nous de vous
faire un peintre français pour des
hamburgers français ce pain c'est une
base de pain on les regarde et comment
devant non du beurre 60 g de beurre
c'est très important christian les
quantités sont précises alors une toile
papier un crayon vous noté tu me passent
à la casserole
voilà latella port à lasseube heures je
le mets en tranches dans la casserole
pour le faire suivre à le poser sur feu
très doux et quand ce beurre sera fondue
tu l'enlèves du feu vague d'accords sur
feu très doux l'a pas dit peur d'y lever
vraie mesure qu'on trouve partout qui
s'appelle la levure de boulanger la
voilà elle s'achète en petits paquets
qui font 44 g on s'est vraiment c'est
les enfants 15 grammes ce qui nous fait
un bon tiers je partage en trois tiers
un bon tiers de ce pack est là et je
mets cette l'urbain c'est dans un
saladier
et je l'aimais rdt je les mette pour que
le fonds de plus vital et sur cette
levure
je vais ajouter 15 centilitres c'est à
dire trois quarts de verre d'eau tiède
comme le verre fait 20 centilitres la
moitié les eaux étonnant très bon arrive
à nancy les trois-quarts de verre d'eau
tiède et avec une cuillère en bois
il s'attire que là c'est simple elle
aurait pas de problème je remue pour
faire fondre la levure dans l'eau tiède
et devant moi j'ai du lait en poudre du
lait en poudre les voyez une raison à
huy alors si vous utilisez du lait
normal
eh ben ça va pas je mets trois cuillères
à soupe de ce lait en poudre
tiens parce que le lait normal qu est-ce
qui contient il contient de l'eau
beaucoup de matière grasse
il empêcherait le pain de lever d'accor
prend je mets trois cuillères à soupe de
lait entoure donc un truc comme ça et je
mélange à nouveau laissé fond du regard
de question et toi ça te fait pas on
peut l'enlever déjà ça va finir on
enlève le dg de la chaleur voilà avec la
chaleur de la casserole bien et
maintenant
j'ajoute d'un coup d'un seul combien de
farine 350 grammes de femmes là je te
fais confiance
les quantités sont précises il faut pas
les oublier un et là je mélange et vous
allez voir ce que j'obtiens n'est pas
extrêmement nourris à voir c'est parce
que c'est pas fini
alors bon mois pour cette recette je me
suis servi d'un gros mixr car ça va
aller beaucoup plus vite
cela dit on peut faire la même opération
avec vos petites menottes mais c'est
plus long le faisait les boulangers
autrefois qu aurait assez merveilleux
boulanger d'autres fois il ya toujours
des bourrins maui alors qu' il faut dire
qu en amérique on parlera alors de la
viande américaine autant la viande
américaine est bon autant leur pain non
ça alors là soyons clairs et n'atteint
le pain non l'avion
si on enlève le couvercle cité plus de
la forêt y regarder ce que j'ai fait
j'ai pris le couteau en plastique car
ces appareils sont livrés avec deux plus
tôt et je mets cette espèce de pâte à
spa très belle dans le grand mix r comme
ceci je referme le fixeur s'étendant
pour exiger la découverte et je commence
à attend il est bien mis quoi donner un
petit coup
là
je vous montre ce que ça donne vous
allez voir que c'est pas très joli à
voir un mais c'est normal
alors puisque quelque chose de très
important vous dire c'est que quand on
fait une pâte à pain on ne n'ai jamais
le sel et on ne met jamais le sucre a
même temps qu'on met la levure car ça
empêche la levure de monter le travail
et c'est seulement maintenant que
j'ajoute par le petit trou qui comme qui
dirait est fait pour ça une cuillère à
café de ce2 ce2 sucre et une demi
cuillère à café du pont avait le sucre
c'est fini le demi cuillère à café de
sel fin la levure a fait son effet et
j'ajoute toujours dans ce trou à tort
une de peur qu'ils me donnent voilà neuf
ans en caoutchouc en cage
ah oui pour j'ajoute les 60 g de beurre
fondu bien soigneusement est à nouveau
tu ne se la joue sûrement vous en
nutrition d'accord à nouveau je mélange
vous allez voir que la fin
va se former
en tenant l'appareil n'est pas que l'eau
regarde là pas le prononce à coeur
je sens
on va se
au centre de l'appareil doit tendre
sahara avant de continuer leur garde
oui d'accord la voilà
prenez la famille or là ça fait presque
40 secondes 45 45 secondes moyenne boule
bien centrer et là je vais seulement
maintenant casser un oeuf
toujours dans ce trou il voit là la
porte là il va falloir que tu me tiens
de la famille parce que la société va
voir nasa si on va dans tous les sens
aigles à l'heure où j'ai moins bien
l'appareil
en dessous la de soins de ce que ça y
est j'y vais et là il va falloir tourner
jusqu'à ce que la pâte claque sur les
bords de l'appareil
au départ c'est absolument monstrueux ce
qui se passe regarde reste eric regarde
moi c'est ça une ambiance
alors là il y en a facilement pour 2008
1 a laissé l'appareil comme savons
comment ils appâtent
on se retrouve je continue à les lâcher
dans complément d'environ 1
il a fallu dix minutes 15 tu vois ce que
nous voulons maintenant qui tape bien
sûr les bords c'est que la pâte et
traitent maintenant à gonfler top c'est
fini alors là vraiment tenir la barre du
tout hein j'adore goûter la pâte c'est
vrai d'âge et a laissé un petit peu va
merci alors là qu'est ce que je fais
j'ai une assiette que je mets devant moi
j'ai de la farine en vrac et je vais
farine et un peu l'assiette et là il va
falloir tirer cinq ou dix dents il va
falloir que je prenne la partie relève
comme ça il va falloir que je prenne la
patte d'un coup d'un seul
voyez télé maulin et ça c'est très
important pour faire ces fameux petits
pains au lait bon petit nommé par faire
des hamburgers on vous a donné la
recette nouvelle pour le matin voilà le
petit pain au lait et la regarder cette
pâte
j'en fais un moddeur que je roule d'une
forme bien égal tu vois comme ceci tu
vas comprendre pourquoi tout de suite
christian les mêmes veulent pas dire que
sur ferrer tu peux enlever l'appareil
s'il te plaît alors la regarder la télé
four je la mets devant moi cette plaque
du four
je vais là il est très légèrement sur le
fond christian regarde pas ce que ça
t'intéresse quand même un jeu la ville
très légèrement sur le front comme ceux
ci et ça y est c'est terminé
je vais là partagés en quatre parties
égales
là je prends une partie d'avoir alors
comment lui donner une forme ronde
parfaite
regardez ce que j'ai eu comme idée
qu'est ce que c'est ça ça c'est un type
de cancer voir heureux de conserver je
vais me servir du couvercle qui va me
servir aussi pour fermer hamburger
sandra la même taille jeu qu'a compris
ouais je prends le couvercle jeu les
farines légèrement je prends la pâte et
j'appuie dessus en lui laissant un petit
côté heureux au centre tu vois j'ai
retenu
très exactement la forme que je voulais
et là hop je la retourne sur la place se
sert de mesure je recommence je vais
fermer quatre ronds comme ceci nous
montre les quatre
je vous rappelle pendant que je fais ça
les proportions pour les quatre petits
pains au lait pour les hamburgers pour
ses quatre petits pains il nous a fallu
60 g de beurre 15 g de levure du
boulanger trois quarts de verre d'eau
tiède 3 cuillères à soupe de lait en
poudre 3 150 g de farine une cuillère à
café de sucre en poudre
une demi cuillère à café de sel et un
oeuf que l'on rajoute à la fin et voilà
le quatrième christian regarde alors
maintenant qu'est ce qu'il faut faire il
faut couvrir tout ça ce pain avec un âge
bien propre et m deux heures dans un
coin coup de l'appartement près le
radiateur à l'abri des courants d'air
sûr que la pâte gonfle nous en avons qui
est prête qui gonfle depuis deux heures
christian tu va la chercher et on va les
regarder
côte à côte voire sûr que c'est devenu
sans aucun trucage nous tenons à vous le
dire
alors regardez deux heures après je vous
montre la pâte que je viens de m et
voilà ce que c'est vous applaudit mon
dieu comment vous dit que j'augmente
comme s'est créé deux heures après
qu'est ce que je fais je mets un poivron
sur la plaque que ça c'est pour une
raison précise que vous allez comprendre
tout alors oui et je mets cette plaque
au four pour cuire les petits qu'un très
exactement 25 minutes
le four et préchauffé thermostat 6 et
demi 6 et demi ça fait environ 190
degrés et on se retrouve dans 25 minutes
pour continuer la recette ça vous mais
vous vous le faites le matin pour le
soir pas de problème à tout
10dans s'assemblent vendre à la maison
en 25 minutes ont passé les sépare le
petit déjeuner syndicaux patrons qui
regardez c'est chaud c'est chaud c'est
chaud alors je les mets sur un plat mais
voilà on les oublie pour l'instant c'est
un poivron qu'est-ce qu'est ce que je
vais te demander de faire à tout à
l'heure
pourquoi est ce qu'on l'a fait cuire et
bien de cette façon il est devenu très
tendre et regarde la peau qui va pouvoir
peu de poivre ont la peau va s'en aller
tout seul
voilà alors que celle de mai sur le côté
la barre 1 et on va maintenant vous
parler de la viande hachée de la viande
en général car qui dit au hamburger
vient ici vient ici tu feras ça tout à
l'heure ce plus grand profit de nantes
qui dit au hamburger dit viande
américaine alors vous savez que cette
émission est dans une émission éducative
exact christian et moi même avons décidé
d'aller sur place
voir le texte pour vous nous avons été à
gleneagles noah viendra dernier train
nous avons été au chat encore ok j'ai eu
du côté à l'as bien sûr attendre août et
dressons l'adroit wavre là tout droit au
fond là c'est le rendez vous allez voir
d'ailleurs le film tout de suite ce
ranch extraordinaire et timo n'ya pas
s'aider soi mais ton chapeau vite ton
chapeau
là on était comme ça là bas moi j'étais
une chasse à la pêche
christian lui l'avait sauvé sa peau le
seven et forums du site en souvient à
voile alors là comme se montrer il y
avait six manches pleines voiles et là
nous a mis les cowboys sur leurs chevaux
très axé mois de dollars ca / - oui donc
ça c est alors qu en fait quelle est la
grande différence entre la viande
française et lannion
eh bien c'était eux ils ont la chance
incroyable d'avoir des étendues
extraordinaire ce qui fait qu'ils ont
étudié scientifiquement des races
d'animaux de boeuf qui tient d'ailleurs
à yola qui arrivent là tu te vois là bas
au fola voilà c'est la voilà la perte du
titre essaiera c'est évidemment sont en
liberté dans des étendues énorme
l'âge des bêtes que l'on va t'il est
exactement le même et on a vraiment des
ventes de terminaux
qu'est-ce qui a classé - là c'est moi
l'asie m'ont coupé lyon est ce que c'est
ce que ça veut dire qu'en france on a
une viande moins bonne on man est
différente mais on n'a pas la
possibilité d'avoir une vie aussi
régulière ça c'est très important
alors une fois que l'avion a fait que la
bête a été élevé dans le texas
elle fait un grand voyage dans le middle
west
voilà où nous avons été aussi un
transfert et dans le middle west 190
jours encore on la nourrit d'une façon
que vous allez voir absolument
scientisme origines avec des silos à
grains extraordinaire et là également il
ya des pâturages tu vas voir sur place
les autres tu t'en souviens moi je n'a
pas mangé ses premiers vous allez voir
c'est interdit le voilà alors là ça
c'est dans le middle west
et voilà là sur place les fourrages qui
sont récoltées et les bêtes elle aussi à
nouveau vivent en liberté
voilà les silos à grains vous allez les
voir mais en attendant tu te souviens
les assumer enfin décrocher ces deux là
c'est quelque chose c'est extra voilà mr
cdh et snap énorme regarde comment c'est
fait un truc même goûter des grains
christian c'est tout ce que j'ai fait
est là il n'y a pas de problème la
planète après est tué sur place ce qui
fait qu'un a pas de nouveaux transferts
et elle est débité sur place il n'y a
pas de boucher là-bas tout est fait sur
place et les dernières images
tu t'en souviens le jeu ce soir
extraordinaire hélas le barbecue après
là c'est que c'était chez le levski
c'était quand même oui alors là écoute
je voudrais te faire essayer mon chapeau
comme bienvenue à deux ans sur la viande
hachée qu'est ce que nous allons faire
400 g de viandes hachées fraîches
ça représente 60% du marché la viande
hachée fraîche que vous faites haché
chez le boucher devant vous il ya aussi
de viande hachée
d'ailleurs qui sont des viande hachée
surgelée tout près paix qui sont très
bonnes il faut le dire du mancunien van
nhon 90 jours mais nous nous allons
incorporer des choses dans cette viande
hachée qu'est-ce qu'on va incorporer de
champignons et un homme et un oignon
qu'est ce qu'on a fait champignons union
on les a haché très fin et si j'ajoute
l'oignon haché très fin les deux
champignons achèterait fin je vais
salez légèrement oui en fait ils font
pas comme ça non il n'ya que la viande
le tout aussi un peu nous on a quand
même 1 700 m2 hamburger france mais ici
on le dira
nous sommes fiers de donner la bresque
de la cuisine c'est doré puis c'est pour
vous là c'est pour les jeunes chez vous
si vous voulez vous amuser recevoir vos
amis
bluffé les remettre mes plus belles
histoires comme toujours et là regardez
2e ici qu'est ce que je vais faire je
vais séparer le blanc et le jaune de ces
deux vies leblanc va venir ici sur la
dent on est les champions lario n'y en
aurait eu tout compris le sel et les
jeunes de l'autre côté
car qui dit au hamburger dit
automatiquement et b10 mayonnaise hewitt
à l'heure je vous parlerai des chaînes
des plus grandes chaînes de fast-food
américain qui ont des règles d'une
précision incroyable
voilà bah tiens je me suis trompé
ah ben voilà on parle ans je me suis
trompé alors
wenner bougeait pas regardez c'est très
simple le blanc ici c'est pas plus mal
comme ça
leblanc ici et le jaune à je vais vous
montrer une fois pour toutes comment on
fait une mayonnaise le principe de la
mayonnaise s'est tout de suite une
grosse cuillère à café de moutarde dans
les zones 2 le seul un petit peu du
poivre quand beaucoup et là le truc
consiste à mélanger la moutarde au jour
2 2 et à les laisser reposer ensemble
une minute
qu'est ce qui va se passer le la
moutarde vap réduire les journée à prier
pour ajouter l'huile dedans ça ne peut
pas rater parce qu'on vous raconte tout
sur les autres au froid l'une trop
chaude le chat c'est pas vrai le seul
transfert je le mets de côté et toi tu
mets l'arjel du m'écraser bien tout ça
ensemble
et puis je continue qu'est ce qu'on a
fait on a acheté une belle lecture et en
a deux belles tomates que c'est bon
alors les tomates on les a coupés en
tranches que voilà et la lecture
on l'a également coupée en lamelles et
je vais vous montrer que je peux couper
de la lecture la même jour montrent
surtout comment alors je prends les
trois dernières feuilles de cette belle
lecture no2 même je les roule je les
roule sur elle même comme un boudin est
là avec le couteau je fais des lamelles
de laitue ça vous semble beaucoup sur
quatre en guerre ça n'est pas vraiment
trop voilà c'est terminé
et là maintenant est ce qu'il ya une
minute taille et très concret est ce
qu'il y a une minute non pas encore je
vais maintenant salées les tranches de
tomate regarde d'un côté et une fois
salée je vais les retourner de l'autre
côté car sur l'autre côté christian je
vais mettre un tout petit
peu de mayonnaise voilà ça y est toi
encore un peu et encore des griffes
oui tu n'es pas encore arrivé exactement
résultat que je voulais alors la
mayonnaise regarder une minute que les
jaunes deux sont avec la moutarde lui le
truc emploi tu sais que l'aja prend des
risques en faisant ça elle est petit à
petit j'ajoute l'huile et si ce que je
vous ai dit est vrai ça peut pas rater
cela peut paraît alors petit à petit au
début et vous voyez que petit à petit
votre mayonnaise commence à prendre
et plus on va ajouter d'huile plus elle
va devenir solidaire est comme ça j'y
peux rien ça y est toi bon alors quand
tu as fait ça te légalise bien christian
sur le dessus ce que nous faisons
maintenant tu es un très très bien et
regarder que la mayonnaise et bien nous
pose aucun problème
elle monte gentiment alors si vous
voulez essayer à la maison vous allez
bluffé tous vos amis je vous le répète
l'huile pardon l'huile la moutarde
mélangé au dojo nous deux et un repos
d'une minute
voilà donc la moutarde cuisent les
jeunes de voile j'y suis
j'ai fait un bon verre de mayonnaise
bien ça va ça va alors toi me cette
mayonnaise veut lui a mené un tout petit
peu de parfum en plus je vais y ajouter
le jus d'un demi le résident crédit il
est bien petit si l'enfant va voir d'un
demi-citron là je vais mettre le jus du
citron parce qu'il est tout petit peu de
moyens je vais ajouter ce jus de citron
ce qui va vous permettre de détendre un
peu la mayonnaise pour la comprendre
voilà c'est vrai qu'elle est pas raté un
seul jeu témoins et là je mélange à
nouveau pour avoir une mayonnaise un peu
plus en que liquid oui
les besoins qui va conduire vers quoi et
maintenant que cette mayonnaise fait je
vais tout de suite en mettre un tout
petit peu sur ni tranches de tomate juin
à peine comme ceux ci sur chaque tranche
de tomate que je vais en mettre regard
des questions
une belle de bale iii bell aliant pas on
n'est pas les petits troy bell puis
rafik dans la salade et je mélange et je
fais ça un petit peu à l'avant ce donc
que la mayonnaise pénètre bien dans la
salade la salade voile il a tout compris
alors pour vous les jeunes vous faites
ça la vence où vous en mettez pas tout
va bien alors quand j'ai fait ça je vais
tout de suite je m'amuse et hier je fais
un peu de ketchup faut s'occuper de ça
je sais très dangereux londres et il en
met partout vous comprenez on en
mettrait pas un petit peu je vais
ajouter des ce type dans le reste de la
bayonnaise pour obtenir de l'autre côté
une mayonnaise rose que je reste aussi
devant moi à une seconde je vais écouter
les pins les pins on va seulement nous
en faire deux pour l'instant puisqu'on
n'est que de 1
alors je vous plais pas voyons intérieur
en arrière de ça je vais je mettre le
gril du four
tu ne bouge pas une oreille et puis je
vais allumer
ils vont jamais la grille 1 mfwa vous je
vais allumer je peux pas m'en occuper
mais aussi si tu en as fait encore bon
dieu et blénod j'ai complètement oublié
je vais allumer le gril du four
et ce qui me semblait être légèrement
les pins ouvert à griller comme ceux ci
dessus
c'est ouvert
et puis je vais m'occuper du steak a
alors regardé le truc que j'ai trouv le
feu ici à lui mais lui un tout petit peu
dans la poêle pas beaucoup comme ceux ci
et là toujours mon fameux couvercle de
tout à l'heure le fameux couvercle qui
m'a servi à faire les pins jeu le 8
légèrement je vais partager cette viande
il me faut une petit hamburger quatre
ans huit comme ceci je prends bien la
huitième partie
tu sais que les hamburgers américains
font 44 g 1,03 pas plus nous on était un
peu plus épais c'est pas vrai que les
affluences absolument jeunes et la
viande dedans et j'ai talent
soigneusement heureusement que j'ai lu
les blancs d'oeufs dedans il car ça va
me servir de liaison un comme ceux-ci
j'étale soigneusement banderilles
si sa grille a trop vite et il me le dit
non ça va pour l'instant ça va pour
l'instant je prends le truc je le
retourne
ah non olala de vue bahman j'ai raté
alors là je recommence c'est pas grave
on aura puis ça peut arriver ça doit
marcher 1
on re a puis je retourne me voilà il est
très fin tu vois alors vous savez que
eux il faut que l'avion au laser 1
alors je vais recommencer et pendant que
je fais cuire ses hamburgers et que mes
filles je vous rappelle les proportions
il m'a fallu un poivron rouge qu'on a
fait cuire qu'on a coupé en lamelles 400
g de viande hachée un oignon une laitue
été coupé en tranches de champignons de
paris de tomates 2
pour à la fois mettre les blancs dans
les hamburgers et les jeunes pour faire
la mayonnaise une cuillère à café de
moutarde forte un demi citron un peu de
ketchup de l'huile bien sûr pour la
mayonnaise du sel et du poivre
ça y est les hamburgers sont cuits ça
n'y était pas ils sont dorés voilà
formidable bon jeu j'enlève les
hamburgers du feu
ici je tu m'amènes les pins s'il te
plait je sale légèrement les poivrons
que christian a superbement fait on n'a
pas pris bien je mets un peu de
mayonnaise au fond du pain comme ceci ou
l autre on le voit la regarde je vais
mettre un peu de poivrons dessus comme
ceux ci la très sympathique
mon premier mon premier spectacle et ses
superbes mais il faut aller très vite si
vous le faites avec les mains chez vous
un vase y croise le mois de c'est
christian la la salade mélangée résister
aux coups extraordinaires
christine le deuxième la revoilà ici un
petit creux de salades mélangées
maintenant deux tranches de temane
livraison la route une seulement sinon
ça va déborder partout chez vous vous en
mettez 2 1
tu me repasse le deuxième steak pendant
ce temps je tartine le dessus les
hamburgers avec un petit pont de pair
avec un petit peu de mayonnaise aussi la
sai et va signer le encore un petit peu
de 34,6 peu de salade à écouter un si on
vous faisait sa rentrée face book table
pour lui
avec le chapeau de cow boy
je lève enfin sur assiette un parent est
partagé tunisair pu avoir en question
copé dit
et la voilà je vais vous en partager un
profond montrer ce que ça donne à
l'intérieur on regarde ça christian
regarde moi ces hamburgers que c'est
beau non je dois penser alors il se voit
que tu veux dire je le leur donnez moi
mais c'est tellement beau enfin vous
ouvrez délicatement la bouffe la
bourgeoisie est ce qu'il est
m
[Musique]